good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-2408
object class header
special containment procedures the
foundation
is to infiltrate and control law
enforcement agencies
in areas where goi-0432 activity is
suspected
information regarding the anomalous
activities of goi-0432 is to be
suppressed
mobile task force psi 13 witch hunters
has been tasked with the search for and
elimination of
goi-0432 members scp-2408-1
in the event that a member is captured
alive they are to be thoroughly
interrogated
using any means deemed necessary prior
to termination
the bodies autopsied and disposed of per
hazardous waste protocols
but will task force psi 9 abyss gazers
is to provide security to researchers at
scp-2408-3
individuals attempting to gain access to
scp-2408-3
are to be terminated on-site patrols are
to search for potential access points
which must be securely sealed when
discovered
armed reliquary and biological
containment area06
has been constructed beneath moscow in
order to contain and study
scp-2408-3
description scp-2408 designates
several anomalies associated with
goi-0432
the hunter's black lodge an anomalous
criminal organization
and sarkic cult primarily active in the
post-soviet states
scp-2408-1 are genetically normal humans
capable of undergoing gross physical
transfiguration
known changes include mass increase by
multiples of
two and sometimes three primarily muscle
increased bone density an increase of
testosterone production
with levels approximately 6 times as
great as in baseline adult males
an increase of adrenaline production
with levels approximately four times as
great as in baseline adult males
enlargement of organs in proportion to
increased mass with the exception of the
testes
and adrenal glands which increase in
size well beyond what would be
proportional
and the brain which does not appear to
change in size
the manifestation of non-human
physicalities for example
lupine hercite porcine ercite
cervine and octopine features have all
been recorded
an ability to shift between bipedal and
quadrupedal movement
amplified senses seeing hearing tasting
and smelling things
outside of human sensory limitations
amplified strength speed and
regenerative ability
unlike proteus cronenberg syndrome
scp-24081
instances are able to reverse these
changes while maintaining cellular
stability
it remains unknown whether or not these
transformations can be maintained
indefinitely complete transmogrification
can be achieved within 10
to 30 seconds scp-2408 was discovered
during operation falconraf
operation falconrath involved the
infiltration of goi
0432 known as the black hunter's lodge
or simply the black lodge goi0432
has been linked to extortion murder
robbery
gambling prostitution human trafficking
drug trafficking weapons trafficking and
underground fighting rings while these
activities are not
inherently anomalous the anomalous
capabilities of goi-0432
has had an aberrant effect on their
practice
these anomalies include the trafficking
and distribution of anomalous
pharmaceutical agents
primarily in the form of the anabolic
androgenic steroid
the intravenous injection of
triggers anomalous levels of muscle and
bone growth
continue and or excessive use will
result in proteus cronenberg syndrome
and or death analysis suggests that this
substance is harvested from the adrenal
gland
of an unidentified species of animal and
has thus been classified as
scp-2408-2a
the trafficking and distribution of
a potent narcotic and increasingly
prevalent
club drug normally sold in small glass
vials
it is administered to the body through
insufflation into the sinus cavities
injection has been found to be
universally fatal substance triggers
various sensory hallucinations increased
heart palpitations
increased sexual arousal and feelings of
euphoria
studies have shown the substance to be
more addictive than heroin
these effects are non-anomalous the
substance likely created with
profit in mind but the substance itself
appears to be derived from the spinal
fluid of an unidentified species
and has thus been classified as scp-2408
to the trafficking and distribution of
biological agents
including pathogens and toxins deemed
anomalous by the foundation
the creation and distribution of
represents an exceptionally high level
threat already classified as
scp information regarding the
red death is presently only available on
a need to know basis
victims of goi0432 have been discovered
impaled by large organic spines or
completely torn apart
cadavers display injuries suggestive of
attacks by several different animals
such as bloody hoof prints wounds
consistent with
goring by a horned or tusked animal and
teeth marks of a large
lupine organism the foundation became
aware of goi0432
in wake of the ussr's dissolution when
many anomalies
and documents relating to anomalies were
transferred to foundation control by gru
division
p the existence of goi-0432 would be
further corroborated by former members
of gru division p it appears that they
were unable to fully contain or
neutralize the threat presented
by goi0432 and its associated anomalies
with one source describing the apparent
destruction of the organization on
several occasions
only for it to reappear months later
seemingly strengthened
document gru division p department 5
gsi black lodge gsi black lodge
division p department 5 department
head vp9 gru dnr
23 1959 responsible personnel
ivan p crouppen detail
gsi black lodge designates a criminal
organization
which has augmented its illegal and
deviant activity through anomalous means
gsi black lodge currently operates
throughout the ussr
but is suspected to be headquartered in
moscow at a location
referred to by the criminal class as the
old altar
information about this location has been
primarily gathered
from rights survivor samuel t and
kadinov
executed for criminal involvement once
survival was deemed
no longer necessary interview log
division p department 5 7
3 1959 dnr 12
3 1959 attached to document 12
3 1959. attached is the transcript of
interview of samuel t and kedinov a
former black lodge recruit and survival
of the rights
interviewer due to the loss of subjects
mandible he is only able to respond via
writing
subject has little to no knowledge with
regards to specific anomalies
and appears to have suffered a great
psychological trauma
from his experience subject was
recovered by workers from the sewage
systems of moscow's arbat district
where is the altar i don't know below
i could not see blindfolded
what did you encounter with it tell me
everything you perceived
old temple heathen blackstone
blood meat the champing the drumming
what were you forced to do fight or die
no choice for rock for the glory of the
hunt
i was weak pathetic worthless
how did you escape among the dead blood
fed greats
crawled away blood and meat and bones
deeper
all was black deserved not strong enough
should have been called with honor
agents of mobile task force sci 13 was
officially tasked with the
infiltration of goi-0432
on april 11 1994 as part of
operation vulcan ref mobile task force
psi 13 is a highly classified
joint foundation global occult coalition
task force created as part of project
citra arca mobile task force sci-13 is
designed for the infiltration
of sarkic organizations and the
termination of high
threat members as part of project
citra arca mobile task force sci-13
operatives are trained
in counter-occult stratagems and the use
of corrosive or incendiary armaments
each agent equipped with a sig sauer
p226
modified for the use of incendiary and
corrosive ammunition
under the alias dominic mishkin agent
operated in moscow was a contract killer
in order to develop a criminal
reputation
and ultimately gain the attention of
goi-0432
on january 20th 1995 agents
was contacted by members of goi 0432
and instructed to visit
red lanterns is a popular nightclub or
adult entertainment establishment
located in the golianovo district
employed as a black lodge front
it is suspected of being involved in
forced prostitution
human trafficking and the distribution
of illegal
frequently anomalous narcotics it is
believed that the local law enforcement
has not intervened
due to corruption and intimidation by
goi-0432
agent was not equipped with a recording
device
due to the delicate nature of the
mission instead
information was transferred to the
foundation via dead drop
agent entered the nightclub at 9pm
january 25th
1995 equipped with a sig sar p-226
he is observed being approached by a
bouncer which agents
proceeds to follow after a short
conversation an agent inside the
nightclub reports seeing
being escorted to an upstairs vip suite
overlooking the main floor agents does
not exit the nightclub until 8 am
january 29th 1995.
a message would later be delivered to
the dead drop site at approximately 9
p.m
missive january 29th 1995.
i apologize for the delay i'll start
from the beginning
i was brought upstairs and over to a
circular table where
six men and one elderly woman was seated
otari zvere yosaba leader of gry0432 sat
at the far end
facing an empty chair he told me to sit
and
i obliged had a menacing heir to him
muscular never removed his sunglasses
and i suspect the others were higher ups
but they
kept silent for the most part he dove
right in
skipped the pleasantries said it was
nice to see someone who didn't mind
doing a bit of wet work new blood
willing to spill blood
i remember him remarking the osava said
he was aware that i had no brothers that
was rare
and dangerous to work solo in moscow
informed him that i received a few
offers but told those
cock-sucking [ __ ] that they weren't
worth my time
paraphrasing his response think you're
tough
you speak brave words but maybe you're
just another stupid [ __ ] whose
luck's about to run out
[Music]
he was hard to read his tone and body
language was firm but
hardly aggressive told him those gangs
were weak
i responded why try my luck with the
lowest cards in the deck
the elderly woman leaned to your saber
and whispered in his ear
she was noticeably pale and covered with
unusual tattoos
abnormal for a russian woman her age
made me feel a lot more uneasy than
those thugs
he said your blood's wrong karova
words stuck out to me hard to explain
look it up but you've got balls
i'll give you one chance to prove
yourself there's going to be a little
initiation
a nice way to call the [ __ ] again
paraphrasing he snapped his fingers and
said
for now we drink and be merry
a waitress delivered a bottle of vodka
and several glasses
as per tradition we pawn our own shots
your salva raised a glass
and i returned the favor and we drank
and in a blink
i find myself tied up naked on a cold
floor
a hood over my head and a proper ball
gag in my mouth
not so weird red lantern says a kind of
bdsm theme going on i
figured pouring my own drink would have
avoided this exact sort of situation
maybe the bottom of the glass had a
layer of some kind of tranquilizer
hard to say doesn't matter it all gets a
lot weirder
eventually they came for me and carded
me off it was pointless to fight it
this went on for maybe an hour or two i
remember hearing the sound of old pipes
and flowing water
the air was chill and damp if it was a
scent of
rust and stagnant water followed by an
earthly aroma
there were voices and not all was
speaking russian
zidas nin
something like that gibberish to me but
i'm certain it was psychic speak
they chained me by the neck to what i
would later find to be a pillar or
some kind of support beam they untied
the rug from my wrists and my ankles
pulled off my hood and removed the gank
i was in a dimly lit area resembling an
amphitheater
appeared fairly ancient there were four
other men in similar circumstances
to my own chained by the neck to the
pillar
there was also a large crowd possibly in
the hundreds observing from higher
ground
some wore red and white robes others
were dressed in plain clothes or
business
attire i felt a prick at the base of my
neck and
everything after was a blur i heard
chanting
i remember skulls cracked eyes gouged
a feel of flesh between my teeth
then celebration drugs food women
and flashes of violence not necessarily
in that order
the memories are confused just vague
disjointed images
i apologize for the lack of details i
awoke in my apartment
with my skin still caked in blood
received a tattoo don't remember that at
all
and took me by surprise resembles a
black cyclops skull with horns and tusks
guess they've accepted me as one of
their own
i'll be sure to step out shirtless if
you typed have the surveillance up snap
a few photographs
see if it means anything
the foundation would henceforth receive
bi-weekly mission reports from agents
missive february 4th 1995.
possible geoi 0432 front
343-465 russian federation
first job was gun running more damning
violence against the abraxas arms
i'll have to report beyond that in a lot
of ways the black lodge is like any
other rafter
they're thunks plain and simple and
mostly driven by greed
they're also a lot nastier which speaks
volumes
you can't get much lower than bradford
they discarded any trace of honor they
had left in serbia
the great mothers is certainly something
you don't see in the world of organized
crime
the breivik called them hags crohn's
witches and they're like no not to their
faces
the saggy influence is clear with them
12 in number
they refer to each other as sisters
priestesses or some such
all wear the same outfits a black
seraphim a stained leather apron
and a red and white shawl covering the
shoulders in air
always barefooted a lot of ink work too
they aren't carcasts but they still
wield a great deal of clout
over the plaque lodge
missive march 10th 1995.
criminal underground has a literal
meaning
for the black lodge there's another
world beneath moscow
abandoned soviet bunkers the metro too
forgotten crypts but it runs so much
deeper than we knew
there's something downright ancient
below survives to say
i think moscow was built atop a sarkic
temple there's a dungeon
rusted torture equipment pre-revolution
maybe a relic of the time of troubles
regardless it looks like the sarcoids
are continuing the tradition
it's not nearly as deep and ancient as
that wretched temple
might be worth researching what
buildings used to exist in the general
location during the 17th century
i don't know much about these places yet
information seems to be on a
neat to know basis but i think i found a
weak link in their chain
one of the great mothers that's called
her five
five shows signs of senility she's
gentle
friendly and more importantly naive
i've been able to glean some fairly
significant intelligence from her
but i can't say much truth there is to
any of it according to her the black
lodge is something both
new and old like the other brother it
began in the gulags of siberia
during tsuki boini avgus diosava
father of otari appears to have been
responsible for the black lodge's
resurrection in 51
something he encountered in the siberian
wilderness after leading a successful
prison break and that's when the witches
sort him out
guided him showed him what he had
forgotten and asked what she meant by
that but
her mind wandered elsewhere she seemed
happy to have someone listen to her
a chance to feel nostalgic about the old
ways she told me to take this
secret and handed me several old and
frag documents
scriptures but not the originals notes
she must have transcribed from their
primary sources
fragmented but something i think
researchers would like to see
i'm going to write this all down five
also told me about moscow's lost history
in another time it was known by a
different name orrock's fall
a psychic settlement and where the saint
of war
sacrificed himself for the blood of gods
and tyrants
never cared for this city because there
was always something sinister here
as she described the ancient city her
terminology was unusually anatomical in
nature
referring to different locations as the
heart
lungs and skull of auroch's form
misup april 18 1995.
i'm making a special request to have my
name as well as what i've done
you'll know it's soon enough removed
from the final report
if i successfully complete my mission
and come out of this alive then i
request immediate application of
agnostics
most of my targets have been degenerates
and criminals
potential rivals and the like but this
was different
and harry that sick [ __ ]
wanted us to leave a different kind of
message there are the sake cults in
moscow
non-black lodge i'm talking oligarchs
government officials
one of them sent word that someone in
the ministry of internal affairs
a man named wanted to crack down on the
black lodge
and was searching for allies among the
few straight players left in this city
target the family a wife a daughter
that don't kill them make an example
the sort of scars that'll never heal
missive april 22nd 1995.
spoke with fire again still trying to
clear my head of what happened
she's not like the others and i'm
beginning to question just how senile
she really is
when she speaks of me and her faith
there is a tone of regret
i asked her more about sarcasm don't
worry i
didn't say the s word and when she tells
me about ion
i feel like a child again listening to
my babushka talk about
jesus and the old prophets whimsical and
like her skipping over the parts that
involve glorified torture and murder
i'm no researcher historian theologian
or whatever
but i think these cults this sarcasm
didn't begin this way well i suppose
that goes for most religions
five talks about honor friendship virtue
and liberation the gentle reindeer folk
of ali um
against the evil deva she's old but i
take it the faith changed long before
her
maybe she's begun to interpret the text
differently maybe she's wrong
seeing good underlays of madness and
atrocity
i can relate it's always the same
another failed revolution regardless
i suspect five is an aberration
perhaps that is the reason why she's
confided in me
the others talk about the great mothers
so they can see
things and at times i wonder if she
knows who i really am
and then my training tells me to
eliminate her
i think i'll ignore that training for
now besides
no point talking out of source like her
not yet at least
p.s the arena it isn't
just for initiation bloodsport disguised
as ritual
oh maybe ritual disguised as bloodsport
sex enter only one comes out a lot of
the folks willing to pay to see and bet
on it
many wear the skulls of beasts and clean
the suits of billionaires
five's not a fan it's like listening to
people complaining about the
commercialization of christmas
i know the black lodge has been
classified as neo-sake but the great
mothers are pretty clearly proto-psychic
they're traditional celebrate the high
holidays and
still think in terms of some greater
good
the rest only care about how to make
themselves stronger wealthier etc
otari has an animal cunning to him but
he's hardly an intellectual
nor does he appear to be a caucus or at
least the term hasn't been thrown around
at all
missive may 1st 1995.
they've got me working in this dungeon
but they don't literally call it that
as i said before i'm certain this place
was in use well before the revolution
i wonder if the tsars knew how many
they'd more or less sacrificed atop an
altar
maybe they did it wouldn't be a surprise
sarcasm is a disease and has more
carriers than we ever imagined
they actually call it the basement's
basement
somehow creepier than the dungeon
torture the information gathering not
that it's irreliable
examples are made one last warning not
to cross the black lodge
organ harvesting too you'd think these
psychic types would have them growing
from trees
sometimes it is just to satisfy otari's
sadism
there's one cell that's different
astabovic about it
said he didn't know and that he didn't
need to know so neither did i
a heavy door different from the rusted
bars of every other cell
built with a small slit to peer through
another for food
inside i saw a man or what was left of
him
his face at least the eyes and nose were
gone
the whole area carved out and now just a
gaping hole
[Music]
and reminded me of a cyclops like the
hole was gazing back at me
kind of like that tattoo so there may be
related
he was sitting on the floor nude and
cross-legged a muscular body covered in
tattoos
scars and dried blood chain linked hugs
held his body in place so
he couldn't move even if he wanted to
i honestly thought he was dead at first
but i could hear his heavy breathing and
see the slow expansion and reduction of
his chest
i have no idea what to make of him
missive may 6 1995.
five let me in on a little secret otari
has a brother
by the name of mikhail same father
different mother
and he's that half dead thing in the
cell
[Music]
apparently otari and the kyle have
somewhat of a rivalry but that isn't why
mikhail's been imprisoned and defaced
five was vehement about that it seems
that mikhail volunteered for some
sort of ritual things get pretty [ __ ]
up here
not sure if it's drugs or not i'll leave
a vile with this report
i'm seeing things the angles in the club
and everything below are wrong
the architecture gives me a headache if
i stare at it too long
yesterday i work in a bathroom stall
with a half-eaten woman
the haulers at red lanterns they look
human one moment
and the next well i know monster isn't
really appropriate in this line of work
but i'm not sure how else to describe
them
they stare at me with feral hungry eyes
five once called the rusalki i thought
she was just being figurative and
i'm not so sure they slither off to the
back rooms with
fresh meat tailing behind they'll be
back an hour later
looking satisfied but the men that go in
don't
ever come out and when i watch the pit
fights
there are things in the audience that
aren't entirely human
there are sounds i can't explain like a
heartbeat
sometimes roars something deep from
below where all the blood and corpses go
[Music]
agent was declared missing in action on
may 28
1995. on june 4th
1995 after much deliberation
raids were conducted against multiple
black lodge sites
including the red lanterns nightclub
during the assault
scp-2408-1 were directly observed
undergoing transfiguration despite their
aggression
and anomalously augmented combat prowess
the scp-2481 threat was thoroughly
neutralized through the use of
incendiary armaments
with the foundation unexpectedly
suffering only minor casualties
as operations continued it grew readily
apparent that the black lodge had
provided minimal manpower
a mere fraction of its total population
in the region
the mission would result in the
discovery of scp-2408-3
scp-2408-3 is a megalithic temple
complex located within a large deep
cavern beneath the city of moscow
approximately 3000 years old it is the
oldest standing structure in russia
and is the type site of the sarkic
culture group
composition comes in two forms inorganic
and organic its inorganic portion
encompasses the exterior
and is constructed from stacked
megaliths of gambro
commonly known as black granite its
organic portion fills the interior
and is composed of bone muscle and
viscera
found among the grounds of the complex
was a gladiatorial arena
and a large altar from the cavern
ceiling dangled the remains of 12
elderly women
apparently disemboweled and hanged via
their own intestines
iron grates on the floor are similar to
those found in meat processing plants
and are likely designed to capture blood
and general viscera
access restricted to level 4 or
authorized citra arca personnel
scp-2408-4 is a humanoid organism
located directly beneath scp-24083
horizontally positioned with its arms
and legs outwardly extended
entity is apparently disabled or
immobile and is likely brain dead
genetically human albeit with many
normally dormant genes being expressed
scp-24084 displays many features that do
not naturally occur among humans
save for certain genetic and almost
universally fatal deformities
these include a single eye located in
the center of the face
flat nasal slit rather than a protruding
nose
tusks horns and various other corneas
protrusions
three rows of sharpened teeth enlarged
relative to its size
and heavily muscled jaws partial
exoskeleton
in coincidence with an endoskeleton both
skeletons being anomalously strong with
a tensile strength comparable to carbine
scp-24084's most notable anomaly
is its size with an estimated standing
height of 300 meters
and a weight of 70 to 72 000 tons
far larger than what should physically
be possible for a terrestrial animal
based upon the unusual length of its
arms relative to the rest of its body
scp-24084 likely moved with a gate not
dissimilar from that of a gorilla
further dna analysis resulted in the
discovery of certain inconsistencies
which has resulted in the hypothesis
that scp-2408-4 achieved part of its
anomalous biomass
through the absorption of potentially
more than a hundred thousand human
and non-human organisms scp-24084
can only be directly accessed via three
distinct shafts
two of which are equipped with
mechanical lifts analogous to those used
in mining operations
each shaft connects to a specific region
of the body for example the skull
stomach and the groin and it is feared
that the creation of further shafts
would result in structural instability
potentially endangering a large area of
moscow the passage to the stomach which
lacks a mechanical lift appears to
directly connect to the arena
ultimately providing scp-24084 with
sustenance
the bronze tips of over 3 000 arrows
harpoons
and spears belonging to a wide range of
eurasian cultures
have been extracted from its muscle
tissue an exact cause for scp-2400
current disabled state remains unknown
and some portions of the body appear to
be undergoing slow decay
while other parts appear to be
regenerating
scp-24084's body is believed to be the
source of scp-2408-2a
and scp-2408-2b evidence indicates that
prior to its discovery by foundation
operatives
certain scp-2408-2 producing organs and
glands
were surgically removed such as the
adrenal gland
pineal gland testes and hypothalamus and
likely smuggled out of moscow by members
of goi-0432
the secure containment of these
anomalous organic objects is of the
utmost
priority at present goi-0432
has expanded its influence while
scp-2408-2b addiction has reached
epidemic proportions
with long-time addicts developing
unusual physical traits
for example leathery skin black sclera
yellow irises
skeletal protrusions and various other
mutations
unable to contain those addicted to
scp-2408-2b
overwatch has ordered the capture and
humane termination of affected
individuals
at designated kill sites remains are to
be disposed of per hazardous waste
protocols
unless authorized for research this
order will remain in effect until
scp-2408-2b is properly contained
and or eliminated
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening
if indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
sister intern
professor puffer the morrigan
retalias chris ball
karim el ashmuy big onion bean
sayo dio demnatus revenant
brian sanchez patrick bailey
matthew gilmore eric corbis
kawaii fire keeper longinus
carcass death aqua king madding
james sabha and nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
vorgen
thank you
you